a sheriff is gaining attention for what
he did at a protest in Flint Michigan
take a look at this we want to be with
you all for real so I took the helmet
off the laser batons down I want to make
this a parade
so that is sheriff chris swanson he
stripped off his right here and he
walked with protesters and he told us he
wanted demonstrators to know he supports
them we walked another mile and a half
and we shook hands and hugged talked and
you saw this whole tension just
dissipated with the crowd
law enforcement has to come from behind
the desk behind the conference table
behind the podium and get into the
community and talk this wasn't it just
this wasn't just a one-off in Louisiana
ktal TV caught this police officer
consoling and hugging a young man this
played out yesterday at a black lives
matter March in Shreveport and officers
from different departments in Florida
took a knee during a Miami area protest
in prayer and solidarity with
demonstrators Gayle Pulitzer
prize-winning journalist Jonathan
Capehart we did it the video of sheriff
Swanson was quote something my heart and
soul needed to see mine too and there
was another share there was another
Chief of Police
Andy Mills as Santa Cruz you see that
because there's such a difference guys
between the protesters and the looters
we have to make that distinction and not
lose sight of what is happening out
there and why it's happening so for the
police to join in with the protesters to
say we're with you we stand with you we
understand you is huge they're focusing
on the people who are exposing the pain
not exploiting it it made it lifted my
heart as well Vlad